hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play folk us now
this is a game that's been on my radar
for quite some time it's not exactly new
but it's always been interesting to me
so I'm gonna give it a try now I don't
know a lot about it other than that the
world isn't always what it seems
something said I went to sleep one day
and oh hello okay alright then there's
that camera proceeded to zoom in and cue
to zoom out hello down there yes see
this is what what made me curious ah
don't worry about me I'm fine like this
I usually like to spend my evenings
almost crushed to death by large objects
it's my hobby yeah let's go with that
hey you know what you should talk to
somebody else
there should be eleven of us around here
I'm just gonna rest up for starters
Cecil is over in the garbage game having
a crisis go check on him well this game
is off to a strange start see I knew
that this was the mechanic of it I just
didn't know anything else about it this
was made for a game jam I believe
someone's in the
oh there you are wow you are tiny
goodness it's so high-pitched you can
hear cuz he's tiny also I'm losing my
voice again but that's besides me ah ah
ah that's a dot don't act like you've
never wanted to just scream from it all
it's too much out there poverty war
disease abuse also why don't women find
me attractive I'm mad and quiet all I
could just symbolically punch a window
that's how severe this is maybe women
don't like you because you're sitting in
a garbage can
you're not even listening probably oaths
are actually what sit for a second just
like that idiot Marcello Marcello he
never listens to anybody all he ever
does is stare into the void sitting on
the edge of the windowsill he should
just stare into his own void like me
alright friend you seem a little bit
perturbed who's over here Vanessa who's
over here see anyone what I see
something god is so weird and sorry
about the resolution of the game it's
awfully strange because it's what I
don't see anyone on the windowsill oh
wow you are tiny teeny tiny it's
beautiful isn't it maybe times like this
I feel wistful times like this I feel I
can say words like wistful some people
say this void can take your soul but
that's ridiculous when none of us have
one
why not if anything the void can fulfill
you comfort you that might be the
romantic in me talking speaking of
talking I'd love to gab more but I think
I need some more quiet reflection avoid
is so awe-inspiring I almost want to
leap into it well don't do that anyway I
think Milly could use some conversation
last I hear she was on the third shelf
left side goodness gravy how was I
supposed to see you oh there's a tiny
dot oh man that is in this this game is
messing with my mind a little bit and
I'm losing my voice because I've been
pre recording him weak third from the
top a third from the bottom because I've
been huh oh I got you Oh annoying that
is something else what were we doing all
that time what what an [ __ ] what he
never said he loved me not once I should
have known did you get cheated on god
I'm an idiot
after all our time together
so he'll say
are you Oh climbing up oh okay
I hate him goodness but but oh my god
oh no that's the same one Wyatt god this
is messing with my brain I can't help
but cry what is going on here so
confused so disturbed what's wrong with
me I need to get a grip Lou I'm just
writing all of my problems
without telling him who's him by him oh
oh what Oh goddamn
Oh sigh maybe I should actually good
lordy let me just oh there you are
now this file read the last ones done
maybe I should before deciding our
entire future together
woah ask him out what you haven't have
asked him out but that's so scary um I'm
kind of in the middle of something here
if you wanna bother someone Peter is
hiding under the pillow okay well you're
so talkative before god this I see you
there I see you I I don't want to go
anywhere I'll just stand up spending
money I'll just stay here and do nothing
all day I need to save up I want to be
happy and not have to worry about money
I'll need lots of it frugality so sorry
I don't want to do anything could you do
me a favor though he throws for lunch
the other day at $10 think about it
I could be dinner for a week I can't
sleep at night knowing that money it's
just out there
I think he's typing by the computer
thanks for your help okay someone's a
little crazy about money
I took more tea mom I suppose all no
thought I saw how oh there you are
I got you oh Jesus you all you people
jerks [ __ ] I don't know why I'm
bleep inscribe there can you believe
this [ __ ]
how can be Bobby Joe cubed [ __ ] sick can
you even fathom what a waste of humanity
is sometimes my faith if you could even
call it that a shattered [ __ ] with the
foob if only everyone could be as
reasonable as me perfectly anyway better
to go [ __ ] himself
it's only $10 he needs to [ __ ] relax
I need to check out my site so see ya
where is that mouse where's that footman
Oh Sookie
supposed to look at the mouse's how was
that a hint to look at the mouse
I don't say one on the nose how do they
do this by the way of curious
maybe if I go back to here he doesn't
want to give you his money
hey there got the cash you've said good
that guy is such a dick
screw him him his tiny little computer
life
IOP ends up with nothing io police takes
that mouse and pushes it into the void
so it's pushing this mouse a thought as
much
but where but where I don't see anything
on the mouse no a maximum zoomed in I'm
not seeing anything you do keep lease
key maybe in front of it
okay what about are you Elise weird
Elise were you hired Milly
Oh
well here's the mouse I just don't I
don't see anything to the mouse oh there
you are
Wow how did I miss you penis penis penis
penis penis did you laughs OH
did anyone out there laugh raise your
hand in the comments if you laughed
don't talk just raise your hand
yeah yep not gonna lie I'm a comic
genius even that loner Jackie needs to
admit it jackie was on the right side of
the second top shelf if I remember right
okay yeah a vagina
haha okay the second top shelf so that
would be this way
where you are gotcha
Lise said I was a loner I am one yeah
I'm alone but I wager I deserve it
I deserve loneliness you ever looked
straight into someone's eyes and say I
love you I love you but not mean it in
the slightest ah ha ha I meant it
I've done it I'll keep doing it over and
over again I'm missing a circular
connection somewhere maybe I just need
to meet the right person but even if I
do there's nothing inside of me on the
end I'll look right into their eyes say
those three words maybe you're better
off talking so taking to someone like
Jim she's somewhere around the door
handle all right jeez these guys are a
bunch of Downers
seriously I'm falling into a routine
wake up go to work come home watch TV go
to sleep on the weekends I sleep maybe
call a friend out to dinner but then
nothing then otherwise what I feel like
there's enough time for anything but no
time at all this problem is so small and
inconsequential but what is this feeling
growing inside me I don't know what to
call a new a new e fresh and boredom
lady giving it a name doesn't seem like
it'll do anything I feel a headache
coming on
I better go to sleep have you been
standing there a while got nothing
better to do my friend a most buy the
guitar I could use some company
okay I didn't even know there was a
guitar in here
we're on the guitar I don't write on it
I'm writing a song that I hate for a
person I can't stand it's the best song
I've ever written and it's for me oh
come on you guys we've gotta be such
down but hey whatever just keep rolling
along with the bunches of light I used
to dream that I'd make something
beautiful full of love now I'm just
amazed if I can [ __ ] something out and
after you without hurling myself into a
manic depression anyway this song is
about someone I love deeply is now with
me no less said about him the better
well if I really believed that I
wouldn't be writing a song about him Oh
now would I look forward to the song I
don't know what I'll be done I'll let
you know the meantime why don't you talk
to my former love Benny is probably
hanging around the room lamp not missing
me at all goodness gracious so sad all
of it bet you let him oh no that's not
him whoops
um who's got to be on one of these edges
since try Moll consecrated sequentially
God is so weird
hello goodbye I don't have time for you
right now
now there must be the other side I see
you you were literally hanging I guess
is this a dream or is this what is
actually happening it's more likely
finding tiny people and listening to
them spending a life of voiding problems
constantly hanging off a light fixture
for dear life hoping in vain for someone
to rescue you my name is Benny but who
are you whoever you are I hope you
enjoyed yourself because right now I can
feel the end coming on here it is right
out of the void
what oh my hi
when I woke up I was still tired but I
had to start the day
oh that gave me chills
there you have it everybody focus that
was an interesting experience to say the
least I mean definitely not your
traditional game game but I hope you
guys enjoyed it nonetheless if nothing
else to listen to my voice lyrically
read that out to you man that was that
was quite depressing you know I hope
that didn't like put anyone down or
anything I you know and I hope you guys
didn't relate too much to like the
individual personalities I think like
that's kind of a part of it like they're
representing like a different facet of
the personality of whoever was like the
main guy in there and then something
else but either way don't let that get
you down you're all beautiful people and
I believe in you I've said that before I
believe in you guys so long as you
believe in me and you believe in
yourself so stay beautiful because you
can do anything no matter what don't let
anyone put you down okay that's all the
words of wisdom that I've got for this
one my need to give my voice a rest
anyway I've been pre recording a lot
because I'm going to LA to fix up all my
new place and get computer setup over
there I might do via log when I get
there but anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
we gotta go because he's gonna be fine
this is
you know